[Music]
nice to talk to you especially because
you've been traveling you've been all
over the world promoting men in black 3
I have I have we went we've gone to
Seoul Korea Russia we've been to Japan
we've been to London we've been all over
the place seven countries three
continents in 12 days and I just got
back and I know you were at the right
show what's the reception like is it I
mean it's all these different cultures
what's it like what are you we went to
you know I'm not used to this stuff man
I do it you know the goonies was a big
deal and then after that it became a
very real deal you know doing movies
that nobody saw and then you know and
and then this thing happened and being
around Will Smith is just it's
unprecedented you know Johnny Depp and
Will Smith are probably the two so we
get out of cars and we go to 8th my you
know eighth of a mile long red carpets
we broke the world's record in Berlin
for attendees in a premiere 7,000 people
right so it's insane so people get out
you just well will will crazy will and
he loves it man he goes thank you thank
you and completely takes it in and then
you hear one guy say like Josh Borland
[Music]
Rowland but no no it's it's just what it
you know there was a lot of actually
attention and all that and my publicist
was like oh my god they actually know
who you are here was like of course I
did The Goonies and she's like no I
didn't think that they know who you are
but I suppose is supposed to blow smoke
up your ass no I don't need that man I
need good it reminds me of when I first
got started in television and I went to
my first Emmys and I'm going down the
red carpet you know they shout out
people's name and this one photographer
called it Conan Conan and I turned him
as like yes and he said you're blocking
Jason Priestley when they ask for your
autograph
and you go please please please please
and you sign it and they go what's your
name I can do better than that when I
was first getting started but people
were at some event people were saying
your autograph your autograph when I
signed it and then I went into the event
I came out later on and there were a
bunch of scraps of paper with my name on
it
you know I gotta get it I gotta get it
huh and then you get a documentary
exactly yeah yeah I moved on now what is
the weirdest question you get your
overseas what's the weirdest quite know
what the questions over there are really
intelligent it's here that you get the
weird questions it's here it's like
right you know the alien questions if
you were to neuralyzed somebody who
would you neural eyes if you go back in
time and all that the toughest thing
about traveling through you know
internationally is the translation you
know and I don't mean to insult anybody
or any of that but you know with like
say we're in Korea and they'd be like
okay we have a question for you great
Josh would you do beneath bunch of it to
do so leave it ajar what's today we're
just gonna check it out wasn't it
what that means to do which is that
literally goes on and on and then I look
at the translator and she goes how was
it playing Tommy that's it are you lazy
are you tired
have you ever done I did a talk show
once I'm Germany really that was very
good was very good it's so hard because
you have to give you ear pieces and you
know you sit there and it's a show just
like this but it was in Cologne Germany
the Harold Schmidt show and the guys
interviewing me and he asked me a
question in English then I wait and it's
he'd know then he turns and says it to
the audience in German then I have my G
I have a joke in my head and I say on
the chicken cross road to get to the
other side and then there's a long pause
and then he turns and in German he's
like I see television and then they just
would stare at me example because
chicken cross will get to the side
terrible joke in Germany in Germany they
hate that joke but but it's very strange
I think traveling constantly I mean it's
unbelievable it's six or seven premiers
every you know every night you have a
huge premiere and then you're doing
things like you know we were in Madrid
and Roger Federer wins the Madrid Open
and then we go to a different stadium
where they're going to show the movie
and they give will and Iraq it's that
big and we're supposed to hit bald men
and black balls this big into the
stadium and it's just stupid when you
sort of step outside your body and look
at yourself and think what is what has
happened what is in a stadium hitting
giant tennis balls with Will Smith right
right but then you go like this who's
going to see men in black 3
so ladies all be stupid this is good